i think this moment is going to be more
iconic than we all realize
right now you know that's obviously
that's what we want the goal to be you
know to look back in 10 years and be
like man i remember
today april 1st 2019 like the start of
something great
that's odell beckham jr on the first day
of the off-season program in cleveland
he had a media session with baker
mayfield jarvis landry miles garrett
they all answered questions at the same
time there's a i yo is a great vibe in
cleveland now especially in light of all
the crap they've been through the last
20 years after the team moved to
baltimore became the ravens you're not
supposed to mention that ravens fans get
upset brown's fans get upset but it's
true then the browns return to the nfl
in 1999 they've been to the playoffs one
time since then it's been 17 years since
they qualified for the postseason
there's been a lot of bad bad seasons
it's a happy time it's a positive time
chris and look i mean they're doing a
victory lap without a victory but
there's still something to be said for
being excited about what may come for
the cleveland browns that's right i mean
they're allowed to be excited and pumped
that they got a young core that's
probably as electric as any core we've
seen in the nfl i mean i like that
they're embracing this young core with
jarvis landry miles garrett odell
beckham jr baker mayfield that they're
all there in support of o'dell being
signed and this is the future of the
browns we're embracing these
personalities and stars we have you know
let alone hey david and joku's not even
there nick chubb's not even there you
know hey denzel ward was phenomenal last
year at the cornerback position the
number four pick of the draft there's a
lot to be pumped about in cleveland and
i think at the end of the day this is
the start of something magical i i
really i think between steve wilkes
being a defensive coordinator that was a
that was a great move uh thanos aka john
dorsey and some of the moves he's made
once again in free agency and then
freddie kitchens and the way he has
about him and what i saw from that
offense
at the end of last year i just go damn i
know it's the off season but they're
going to have to try hard to really
screw this up
and as long as they can hold it together
and show some sort of maturity and love
for football which i don't think is
gonna be an issue for this group uh yeah
i expect cleveland to be be there come
playoff time next year
it was so funny last week when we had
john dorsey on the show and you started
calling him thanos and he was like he
was like
messing with me like is this good is
this bad i don't know who this thermos
guy is that was my reaction right i
started doing it a few weeks ago all
right so the question we're gonna ponder
over the next few minutes here
where is the best young core of players
right now in the nfl is it the browns
when you consider they've got baker
mayfield odell beckham miles garrett
jarvis landry let's throw in denzel ward
all under the age of 27. is that and
look if you're watching on nbcsn i mean
there are guys beyond that that we
didn't even include in that nick chubb
kareem hunt yeah this is impressive
oh he's on there sorry yes but yes but
he is i'm saying we didn't include when
we started rattling off names there's a
lot of guys on both sides of the ball
who could become star players and some
already are star players but other other
teams chris who would you think of that
have that young nucleus of high-end
talent that can compare with if we just
focus on four or five great guys yeah
what other teams out there would you put
in that category i mean
i don't think anybody's got the depth
that of a list like the cleveland browns
but i think if yes you took it to four
or five names hey of course the kansas
city chiefs jump out right away when you
talk about chris jones uh you talk about
patrick mahomes sammy watkins tyree kill
you know travis kelsey i'm guessing he's
about 26 or 27 but they're in 29 29 okay
seems younger than that but regardless i
think of them as being one of those
teams that's in the conversation you
know hey the rams still got some young
talent there but i don't know if anybody
is in the ballpark of this cleveland
browns team when it comes to young studs
uh across the roster do you is there
anybody that jumps out to you i don't
think there's anybody i'm missing here
yeah i mean look if and i keep going
back to the eagles and carson wentz he
is healthy for a full season he's still
only 26 fletcher cox is 28.
28. they just picked up jordan howard
who could be a great player for them
right the only old guy they have is
desean jackson and he's still fast
enough to be considered a young guy so
he's part of that nucleus that they're
trying to put on the field and be
successful with as well the bears the
bears are kind of got another team where
you can you know it might not be all
young guys but it does seem like they
got a lot of 27 28 year olds right
yeah khalil mack this is this is year
six for him you've got mitchell trubisky
coming into his own allen robinson who
was a pleasant surprise last year coming
off of the tournament acl signed from
the jacksonville jaguars tarik cohen now
that jordan howard's gone i think we're
to see more from terry cohen right mike
davis one of the reasons that jordan
howard became expendable a guy they
picked up in free agency from the
seahawks so i mean the bears have that
young nucleus of talent as well yeah
they do i think they're in that
conversation you know uh the cowboys
they're they're another team i look at
when you go ezekiel elliott dak prescott
amari cooper you know byron jones on the
defensive side demarcus lawrence all
those guys so uh yeah we got kyle vander
esch good job stats getting in my ear
with that name exactly right jalen smith
that that as i sit here and start
talking shidobi and woozay a corner i
start to go damn yeah the cowboys you
talk about some young studs they're they
are in that conversation in fact they
might be the number two team right
behind the cleveland browns when it
comes to young core of exciting you know
big time future players
well and and you know even though we uh
we from time to time or at least i from
time to time criticize the quality of
quarterback play in minnesota
they've got a lot of young players who
have been locked up to second contracts
who are part of that nucleus and it's
almost like having a great quarterback
is an indispensable prerequisite to
having that nucleus of high-end talent
and whether or not the vikings have that
remains to be seen but between dalvin
cook and adam thielen and stefan diggs
and on the defensive side of the ball
xavier rhodes is only 28 years old
they've got great young cornerbacks that
may push roads off the roster sooner
rather than later they've got great
young pass rushers in the in denial
hunter and stephen weatherly that that
almost pushed everson griffin off the
roster this year so there's uh you know
there's yeah the most i guess i would
say most of the true playoff contenders
have that nucleus of talent that jumps
off the page but you know as we talk
about this chris yeah i keep coming back
to the patriots because the patriots
don't have that nucleus of young talent
no and it doesn't matter no they they
just it doesn't matter and you know i
don't think they look to be a team of a
nucleus of young talent they want kind
of middle-aged veterans who they know
are going to be able to execute all
their different game plans on a
week-to-week basis and sprinkle in some
young guys that they feel like can
handle the mental workload that's put on
you by the new england patriots so they
approach it a different way they're in
more advanced uh they believe a little
bit more as a as a football team and
building purposes they're a little bit
more of quantity over quality right i
mean new england's not a type of team
that looks for just star players they
kind of look for let's we're going to
have a robust middle class as you always
say and that's how i look at them
there's like not a lot of great players
on the team but damn there's a lot of
real good players and good players to go
along with it backing up those real good
players and that's why they can always
withstand injuries and and different
changes and schemes on the offense and
defensive side of the ball because
they're not overpaying certain guys uh
you know on a top-heavy roster
what do we think of the jets with sam
darnold i'm still only 21. le'veon bell
27. paul adams 23. leonard williams is
only 24. i mean they're laying the
foundation for something i don't know
what it's going to become but they're
laying the foundation for it no you're
right i mean you get into those guys
they just get a jameson crowder who's
still at a good age jermaine johnson uh
you said i mean you know even cj mosley
it's not like he's a real old guy either
on the defensive side of the ball the
jets uh you know as i you know kind of
look at teams and on paper and i know
it's early but the jets are one of those
teams i say watch out for a little bit
you know greg williams adam gase i think
they're going to be improvements i think
there's a little more talent on that
jets offense than people realize they
got good tight ends uh you talked about
some of the receivers they got and sam
donald has big time potential with
le'veon bell so
i think the jets are the type of team
that can surprise people and really be a
pain in the butt i don't know if they're
gonna be a playoff team but i think
they're gonna be like that seven and
nine eight and eight team and if they
can make magic happen one or two more
times maybe they do sneak in
you know and i i see sam darnold and we
consider the reality that darnold may
end up being a shortlist franchise
quarterback and
it's gonna become so potentially glaring
if the giants continue to kind of
stumble around in the wilderness because
they could have had darnold yes and i
understand saquon barkley was a can't
miss running back prospect but i'll take
a can't miss quarterback prospect all
due respect over a can't miss running
back prospect and it could be that
darnold and the jets are running circles
around the giants for years to come if
they blow this and don't get a guy that
they need or they end up being three and
13 every year until they get that guy
until they finally have everything lined
up just right and they find the guy they
want obviously of all the teams we're
talking about you know the the giants
had yeah odell beckham jr and saquon
barkley uh which is a nice little
nucleus but uh what do they have now
really
if you would talk about young talent
other than saquon barkley what do they
have yeah sterling shepherd evan ingram
exactly right those are the two names
that at least come to my mind there is
as those two they got you know a young
offensive lineman you know the defensive
side of the ball yeah there's not a
whole lot of you know real young talent
they got some guys in the middle
defensive tackles davin tomlinson as a
good football player but yeah you're
right i mean hey they took they traded
away a huge part of one of the more
exciting you know offensive skill
position players we've seen really when
you put it on paper i mean saquon
barkley odell beckham jr evan ingram and
sterling shepherd that with the new york
giants was i would have put that up
against just about anybody in football
when all healthy but the problem is is
it's a quarterback who cannot take
advantage of the talents of a guy like
odell beckham jr and that became a
problem not only for the giants but for
eli manning and i think ultimately
that's why they traded odell beckham jr
because it exposed them in some of those
ways uh and they didn't want to deal
with that conversation anymore
which afc east team do you believe in
more as a potential threat this year to
the patriots the jets or the
bills gosh that's a really good one
there it's it is between those two
um
i think i'm gonna go with the bills and
a real close one i mean i it's like it's
it's nitpicky there but i do like you
know this i like the bills of what
they're doing sean mcdermott uh as far
as what he's done their number two
defense of football last year and
they've added improvements to the
offense already with josh allen and i
think they'll probably add more into the
draft so and got him some pass
protection where i think the buffalo
bills are
building things the right way and are
really headed in a direction where
they're gonna be very relevant for a lot
of years to come with sean mcdermott as
as the head coach
all right let's take a quick break and i
we chris you put the question on twitter
about the young nucleus i retweeted it
we'll see what some folks say and maybe
we'll have some more to add to this
later in the program for now though
we're going to take a break when we
return have the chiefs done enough to
address their defense this offseason
this in the aftermath of the trade for
emmanuel ogbo we'll discuss that when
pft live continues right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports